Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth. We're going to
get candid with it. Tonight I'm going to
be talking about a game that is one of
the most played games of all time. The
multiplayer game Fortnite. I'm going to
pull this up on screen because I want
you to see this. I typed in what is the
most played multiplayer game and it says
by platform Counter Strike 2, PUBG
Mobile, and Fortnite. You know what? I
actually thought Fortnite was dying out.
It's still in the top three. Uh millions
of people are playing this game
and uh I got asked to share a
presentation with the youth this coming
weekend about gaming in general. So, I
just started digging in, you know, the
addictive principles of these games, how
they're actually creating them to be
addictive. They're actually hiring
psychologists to to know how can we make
this the most addictive game ever. You
know, Fortnite is actually being sued. I
from what I found out it's one of many
lawsuits that they have had. But this
one that's mentioned on ESPN says
lawsuit to allege Fortnite as addictive
as some drugs.
It goes on to say that the parents of 10
and 15y old are saying that their kids
are addicted to this thing. It says,
"The legal action alleges that Fortnite,
when played for a long period, causes
the player's brain to release the
pleasure hormone dopamine in the same
way that some drugs create a chemical
addiction. Epic Games, when they created
Fortnite for years and years, hired
psychologists, they really dug into the
human brain and they really made the
effort to make it as addictive as
possible.
They knowingly put on the market a very
very addictive game which was also
geared towards the youth. So, you know,
just thinking morally, thinking legally,
there's a lot of things out there that
are addictive on the market. Cigarettes,
alcohol, gambling, all these things.
They have an age limit on them. I think
that's very interesting.
Uh, why why are these games addictive?
There's psychological hooks in them.
Games often employ features like in-game
purchases, loot boxes, and frequent
content updates. So, the game never
ends. It's not like back when we were
kids, you played Frogger. That was even
before my time. Frogger, where you just
get the Frog across the road, or Mario,
you beat the game, you play 40 levels,
and it's done. You put it on the shelf
and you completed it. No, these games
never end. They never end. They always
expand. Always a new level, always a new
update. And and they're filled with all
these psychological hooks inside of
them, including loot boxes.
When I looked into loot boxes, this has
been a controversial thing in the game.
They've said there's been people that
are trying to say this is legalized
gambling for kids because you can buy
you can purchase these loot boxes and
you don't know what's inside. So, you're
paying real money to open up this box,
and you don't know if it's going to be
something not cool or something really
cool. Endless progression. Many
addictive games offer continuous
challenges, goals, and rewards that give
players a sense of constant achievement.
So, you're constantly getting that
dopamine hit. Oh, yeah. I just I leveled
up. I got a new weapon. I got a new
costume. I opened a new level.
social engagement. Uh, multiplayer games
foster a strong sense of community and
competition, making players want to keep
playing with friends or to outperform
rivals. So, they feel like there's uh
social aspect to it. I'm I'm playing
with my friends or I got to beat that
dude because he beat me last time. And
open-ended gameplay. Some games offer a
vast amount of content or activities so
players feel like there is always
something more to do.
So, this is a video clip from uh Sai,
what is it called? Sai, the Sai show,
and uh he's going to talk a little bit
about loot boxes and how they're so
addictive and they're just like
gambling. Players are buying and selling
loot boxes that might be filled with
valuable powerups and skins that can be
worth hundreds or even thousands of
dollars. And we mean real dollars. The
phenomenon is new enough that research
is only just starting to come in. What
has been extensively studied, however,
is old school gambling, slot machines,
and the like. These games can be
fine-tuned to keep you playing and take
your money. In fact, we know a great
deal about how your brain reacts to
gambling games and what that tells us
about how game designers can manipulate
your behavior. part of the brain says
you're not being rewarded enough, but
another part of the brain says you need
to keep pushing.
>> So that's that's the the mechanism right
there. That's the trick, the
psychological trick right there is to
make a game that's not too hard because
you'll just give up. Not too easy
because it's boring, but right in the
middle to where it's not too easy, not
too hard, and there's all these level
ups. Like if you didn't beat that boss
this time, keep playing because you're
gonna get that level up. There was a a
guy who worked for these companies and
he said
you it's it's programmed to make you
think that you're getting better. You're
actually getting better at the game, but
you're never really getting better.
You're being rewarded for the time spent
in the game. The more time you put in
the game, the more stronger your weapon
is. The they give you a stronger weapon
so that you can actually beat that boss
that you couldn't beat before. So,
you're being rewarded for time. You're
actually not getting more skillful at
the game, but it's a psychological game.
It's a psychological manipulation to
make you feel like, "I'm doing awesome.
I'm killing everybody." Now, you have to
be 18 or older to scratch a ticket or to
pull a lever. Isn't that crazy? You got
to be over 18 to pull a lever or scratch
a ticket. Yet, these are child's play in
comparison to the psychological
manipulation that's going on in the game
Fortnite.
It's insane, man. This this is we're in
a new world here. So, I mean, this is
literally just like handed a pack of
cigarettes to to some kids. Like, here
here's an addictive substance. Take it
and go play.
Why would as a parent, you know, and and
I know this might be very convicting
sounding, and I'm going to be completely
transparent, completely honest. I I
loved games growing up. My parents got
me a system. I was never addicted. They
like I said, the games were different
back then. You you actually the game
ended after a while. I actually own a
Wii console in the in my living room,
but it's only been turned on like twice
this year. And the games I have are like
Wheel of Fortune, you know? It's like
hangman just trying to figure out how
many what the letters are or the virtual
pool table thing. I haven't even played
the thing. There's no addiction to that.
And I'm not going to say no addiction.
Maybe somebody gets addicted to Wheel of
Fortune. I don't know. It's gambling.
But these games are different. When
you're playing online, you're playing
with community. You're leveling up
constantly. It never ends. These are
psychological games.
But why do they do this? 1 Timothy 6:10
says, "For the love of money is the root
of all evil, which while some coveted
after, they have aired from the faith
and pierced themselves through with many
sorrows." These companies don't care
anything about you. All they care about
is getting that money. All they care
about is that you paid the lump sum to
buy the game. Now you're going to pay to
get the loot box. Now you're going to
pay to get the new weapon. You're going
to pay to get the new level. All they
care about is money, the love of money.
They'll use any psychological warfare
against you to get that money to
continue to come in. They don't care
about you. The love of money is the root
of all evil. But this verse even
pertains to those people who are playing
the game because when you're in the
game, you all you want to do is keep
playing, right? I just got to get that.
I got I got to level up. I got to get
that extra weapon. I got to get that
thing unlocked. That's like the love of
money. It's like I got to keep getting
it. I gota I gotta get more. I got to
keep going. I got to keep playing.
And when that overcomes you, you've ered
from the faith, piercing themselves
through with many sorrows.
That road is a deadend road. Can games
actually be used as good teaching tools,
though? Yeah.
>> So, I've been a pilot since 2004 and a
flight instructor since 2008. And over
all those years, there's a common
question that always comes up and I love
to answer it. Should I get into playing
Microsoft Flight Simulator or something
similar? Will that help my actual flight
training and my actual path into
becoming a private pilot? My answer, I
I'll just give it away. It's easy. It's
a definitive yes. I can't tell you how
many beginning private pilot students I
worked with directly, and I could
instantly tell they had a better grasp
than normal on the stick and rudder.
Now, why was that? Well, because they
had been playing this game.
>> So, he's telling you as a pilot himself,
as a teacher, he said, "I can tell a
difference when somebody has played the
simulators. I can tell it actually helps
them." So, games are actually teaching
you something. They in Abu Dhabi right
now, they're training people to drive on
simulators before they put them on the
road. So, they're they're giving them um
different environments like rain. Do you
know how to turn on the headlights? Do
you know how to turn on the blinkers? Do
you know how to turn on the windshield
wipers? The road's a little slippery. Do
you know how to control it when the
environment is different? When the
weather is different? So, these games
can train you. the military, the police
force use virtual reality to train,
which is really an awesome concept
because how are you going to train
police to handle a hostage situation
without endangering them or without
paying a ton of money for like actors
all day long or something like that?
They've actually created these virtual
reality simulators that help people fly,
people drive, cops.
Like I'm saying, most of the stuff I
talk about when it comes to media, I'm
not talking about the media itself. I
believe that these things are tools. The
TV is a tool. The radio is a tool.
Computer, phone, games,
they're tools. How is that tool being
used? And most of the time we don't have
an option for how that tool is being
used. We're not creating movies. We're
not creating video games. You're going
to the store and you're buying what's on
the shelf. What is being put on the
shelf? Who are these people that are
creating the game? What kind of belief
system do they have? How much money are
they investing to make that game the
most addictive thing ever? Because all
they care about is getting the almighty
dollar, right? So, it's not the the tool
itself, it's how the tool is being used.
So, what are the most popular games
teaching? The most popular games out
there, what are they? Fortnite. What's
Fortnite about? Elden Ring, Call of
Duty, Counter Strike. What are these
games primarily about? If you had one
word, one word to say what is the game
about? If you could sum it up in one
word to tell me what what is the game
about? Kill, right? Kill.
Fortnite. What's it about? Kill. Count.
Counterstrike. Kill. Call of Duty. Kill.
A lot of these games I don't even know
what they are. Doom. Kill. Hades. And
the thing is
so many of the games so many games have
three elements in common. Murder,
sexuality,
and satanic themes.
That's That's not a stretch. You notice
how any female is dressed in a game over
sexualized. What's the main objective?
Kill.
And for some reason, there's just this
fascination with blood and gore and
satanic themes, demons, pentagrams. I
mean, they got games like Diablo,
uh, Cult of the Lamb, all these things.
It's always about glorifying Satan and
actually fighting against Christ. There
are games um what was it? Shinmagami
Teni. You literally fight Yahweh. He's
the final boss. You're running up the
stairs to heaven to kill Yahweh by
rejecting him. Um Bayonetta.
Bayonetta is a naked witch whose main
goal is to kill angels, heavenly angels.
angels that are based on love, joy,
peace, all these things. Like even an
atheist, even if you're not a Bible
believing Christian, what person in
their right mind would say, "Yes, I want
to kill joy and love and hope and peace
and all these things." Why is there such
a fascination with occult themes, murder
and sexuality? And don't even get me
started on Grand Theft Auto. the whole
game, every every aspect of the game is
to glorify sin. So, Fortnite, I just
asked Google, this is the type of
research, I mean, I'm putting air quotes
research because it doesn't even take a
lot of research for parents. If you're
out there and your kids are playing this
game, simply ask Fortnite or ask Google,
"What is Fortnite about?" And it says,
"How to win. To secure a victory royale,
you must eliminate." They like using
this word eliminate. It's kill. You must
kill all other players and be the last
one standing. That's the object of the
whole game. Kill, kill, kill. If your
child or you are putting eight hours a
day on this game, what are you doing for
eight hours a day? You're killing.
Murdering. This is a murder simulator.
We just saw flight simulator, driving
simulator, police training simulator.
This is a murder simulator. What is that
doing to your brain? What's that doing
to your psyche? What is that teaching
you? Because we just saw that these
games, these simulators are a teaching
tool, right? If it can teach you to
drive and how to fly and how to handle a
hostage situation, then these games are
teaching you something. What is it
teaching you? Murder. Be the last one
standing.
Loot and fight. So, I I asked simple
search again. Are there any occult
themes in the game Fortnite? AI is not
not hiding it. Yes, Fortnite
incorporates a cult and supernatural
themes through its storyline,
characters, and in-game events. Here it
says demonic forces, dark magic,
interdimensional beings.
It says a central occult theme revolves
around the cube nicknamed Kevin, a
malevolent,
sentient, and reality altering entity.
And down here it says shadow stones
consuming shadow stones fragments of the
cube. You're actually so this demonic
entity the malevolent sentient reality
altering altering entity
called the cube. You actually consume
parts of it, fragments of the cube that
temporarily transform players into
ethereal shadowy ghosts with enhanced
abilities. Enhanced abilities. So, what
is this teaching? Like we were like
we're talking about the games teach.
What does the game teaching? When you
consume a part of this cube, it actually
gives you a supernatural ability,
something good.
You know, some people might argue like,
"Oh, the cube's the bad guy or what." I
don't know what it is, but you eat part
of it, you consume part of it, and
suddenly you can fly around and you have
supernatural powers. It's It's portrayed
as a good thing. This This is what you
turn into. Isn't that beautiful?
You know, I'm asking what is in this
game? It said magic. So, I looked it up.
Magic. There it is in Fortnite. Magic is
a form of power that was first
introduced in chapter 2, season 6. It
draws its origins from power of zero
point. Underlined here, it says demon
warriors and cubes. There's demon
warriors in the game. So my question is,
why does the game have to always be
about dark magic, about demons, about
spellcasting?
How come the game can't be like, "Oh,
let's try to climb to the top and uh
plant a flag on top of the mountain and
get back down or something." Why does it
always got to be kill? Why does it
always got to be do cast a spell? Why
can't it be oh, dig up a vegetable and
eat it for extra life or something? It's
always got to be potion, spell,
witchcraft, murder. We're going to keep
we're going to see spellless magic. So,
there are some magic that doesn't
involve spells. And it says right here,
it says uh this is the type of magic
used on
oniima.
Now, the reason I pronounce it that way,
I don't know how it's pronounced, but I
see that first word on. And I know what
that word means because I did a whole
documentary on anime with Little Light
Studios, and the word oni means demon.
It's a Japanese word for demon either
through magical artifacts such as masks
of power. So remember these words on
mask of power.
Uh this type of magic requires no
incantation
or magic circle and can be used almost
instantly. So are you is this implying
that there are some magic that include
an incantation and a magic circle?
Because that's straight witchcraft. Like
literally witchcraft 101 runic magic.
That means magic done with runes. It
says this type of magic used by the
imagined order, wizards and witches,
witchcraft, and other entities such as
cubes, demons, and spirits. This type of
magic uses runes to cast magic power.
Now, we're going to look into all this.
What is this stuff? Because all of this
is real. All of this is based on real
occult magic and it's put in this game
that's targeted towards children. And
don't even try to say it's not because
the whole game is made with colors and
it's you know they say there's no blood
and tons of kids are playing this game.
I don't I don't I don't care what it's
targeted towards. They might put on the
cover I don't know if it says like 15
and up. This game is targeted towards
children. That's why it's got all the
bright colors and the no blood and all
that stuff so that parents will say,
"Oh, and you know what? Satan does this
all the time." He loves to make content,
whether that's a series of a show or a
video game like this where in the
beginning it does seem kind of harmless.
Now, this game was never harmless from
the beginning. The whole point was to
kill or be killed, be the last man
standing. But either way, it started out
with this fun, colorful world with
characters that are full of colors and
costumes and there weren't really like
demons and monsters and things like
that, right? No blood. But then as you
progress, as you play the you get
addicted to the game because they
purposely made it addicting, right? They
purposefully made it addictive. This
isn't like, oh, you know, we're sorry
that some people No, we're going to try
and purposely addict you to it like
crack. And now that you're addicted, oh,
now we're going to start putting in the
occult elements. Now that you're hooked,
you're not going to turn from it now.
Same thing with these shows. You get
into a show, you start falling in love
with the characters, and season one was
great. Then all of a sudden, season two
comes out, you can't wait to watch, and
the main character is coming out uh out
of the closet, somebody's practicing
witchcraft and yoga, and all the oult
themes start coming out, and now you're
hooked, and you start compromising, and
you're like, "Well, I don't like that
part of it, but it's okay. Okay, I'll
just keep watching. It just keeps
getting darker and darker and darker and
um you know start glamorizing that the
husband hates the wife and the daughter
is promiscuous and all these things and
there's drug use and alcohol and all
this stuff and next thing you know
you're just watching and being
entertained by a debaucherous household
that is doing nothing but glorifying all
the abominations of the Bible. And so
this game is no different. Let's look
into what is a rune. What is runic
magic? Witchcraft definition for runic
magic. Witchcraft in the context of
runic magic refers to the magical
practice of using ancient symbols or
runes to manifest in in wait intentions
influence reality and connect with
mystical energies. All right, this is
what you're doing in the game. It
involves inscribing runes on objects or
bind runes to create
uh talismans. Oh my goodness, it's right
here. Talismans and amulets that attract
positive outcomes like protection,
wealth, and strength, empowering the
practitioners, spells, and rituals.
So, think about this.
Satan's trying every trick in the book.
every trick in the book to win your
soul. He's trying to brainwash you with
subliminal messages in movies.
Subliminal messages in music
and now addictive games because music
can be addictive. Movies can be
addictive, but they have nothing on
video games because the video game is
different every time you're actually
involved in it. There's a community in
there. There's loot boxes. There's all
this stuff that keeps you coming back.
The game never ex It's not like the
movie ends and the credits roll. How
many times can you watch a movie, right?
You know, once you've seen it two or
three or four or five times, you're
probably not going to watch it eight
hours a day. People are playing these
games eight to 15 hours every single
day. They can't wait to get off work.
They can't they can't have fun doing
anything else. If if these kids uh
parents say, "Hey, we want to go to the
beach this weekend." They're like, "I
don't want to go to the beach." and
they're hating every minute of it
because they just can't wait to get back
on the game, to get back in that virtual
world. Now, look what Satan's done. He's
created this digital drug where nobody
wants to leave. And while you're in
there, you're becoming the character.
You're not just watching a movie where
you're watching a story play out. You
are the character. You're running
around. You're controlling the
character. You choose where the
character goes. Right? So is that really
like virtually vicariously living in
that system doing everything that that
player does?
You become the one virtually casting
spells, virtually doing runic magic. So
Satan has glamorized the occult, got you
addicted to this fake world and having
you do something that you would never do
in real life. Most people aren't going
to get involved in the occult. It does
happen and it happens on a lot of lower
levels, but I'm talking about this dark
magic stuff, spell books, potions,
talking to spirits, all that kind of
stuff. Most people aren't going to do
that, but when they're in the digital
world, they'll do it vicariously because
it feels artificial and fake, but you're
actually controlling that being in that
world. What's the difference in you
doing it in that you're controlling the
character in a fake world? Imagine if
you had VR goggles on and you're in that
world and you're like, "Oh, I'm going to
mix this potion. I mix this potion." Is
it any different than really doing it in
real life?
Where does sin start in the mind?
Everything starts up here. So God's
saying, "Look, don't mess with this
because it's an abomination. Don't don't
talk to spirits because they're demonic.
Don't try and talk to the dead because
it's a demon in disguise." But oh, if
you'll do it vicariously in the
artificial fake world, it doesn't feel
real. But God knows the intentions of
your heart. If you're entertained by it
in that world,
then that's the intentions of your
heart. That's what's really inside that
you really love that thing. You're
really taking part in that thing
virtually. So, Satan wants to keep you
in that world as long as he can because
as long as you're in there, you're doing
his work. you're involved in his
sorcery.
So, this was the name of that word I
couldn't pronounce exactly, but it
starts with the word oni. Oni noima. And
look, it says right there, translated to
island of demon. So, I already picked up
on that word oni. And there it is. It
says also known under the code name
Hermes. What? Her. So, that's what I'm
saying. How come everything has to be a
cult?
Literally, how come every part, every
piece of the game has to be that way?
How how come it can't just be like, oh,
Peach City or something, you know,
Hermes? Really? Uh, the code name
continues the trend of internally naming
the map after Greek deities being
beginning with H. So, this is an ongoing
thing. This just happens to be the one
that I found uh that this island is
called Hermes.
But apparently a lot of them are named
after Greek deities. What does the Bible
say? Make no mention of these other gods
names. And yet here we are living on
their island, playing around, right?
Playing around with the occult in this
demon island of demon. Wow, man. Hermes,
a Greek god of commerce,
eloquence,
invention, travel, and theft, who serves
as herald and messenger of other gods.
That's who Hermes is. Now, Oni, remember
this word onie has two primary
definitions in Japanese folklore. And
oni is a monstrous demonic creature
often depicted as large, strong, and
fearsome, sometimes with horns and tiger
skin.
So when we saw something about the
masks, you can do certain spells or you
can do certain magic without spells.
They called it spellless magic. It said,
"Oh, you just have to wear these masks
to do the magic. You don't have to cast
a spell." Well, this is under the the
page of demon warriors, masks of power.
These magical masks, I think this
quote's interesting. These magical masks
stink of old dangerous magic. A very the
very magic we waged a war to destroy.
So, there was a war to destroy this
occult witchcraft magic. And yet now
it's part of the game where you want to
you want to put that mask on because it
gives you special powers. Here are some
of the masks. Fire demon mask because
oni means demon, right? Remember it said
that they're represented by with horns,
red skin and horns. Um a mask that sends
explosive screaming masks which home
towards opponents. So, fire demon mask,
void demon mask, Shogun X's fire demon
mask, night rose void demon mask. So,
all the masks are based off of demons.
So, this remember this is spellless
magic. You can do magic without casting
a spell. All you got to do is put on a
mask of a demon. Interesting. Now,
elements. If you haven't heard of
elements, elemental witchcraft, earth,
wind, fire, water, you'll see that those
are represented in here. Fire, element,
it says right here, elements, fire, it
says allows the user to manipulate fire
and it's primarily used by demons and
oni masks. Wind allows users to
manipulate wind. And this one is uh
magic primarily used by sprites. Now,
sprites. See, they're they're trying to
get tricky with some of the wording
here. They'll say onie because most
people don't know what oni is. They'll
say sprites because Oh, that sounds
cute. What is that? Most people don't
know that a sprite is a a a ghost, a
spirit or a ghost. Right here, they
continue. The elements continue. Water
element allows users to manipulate
healing water used by the sprites. Now,
this is a sprite in the game. This cute
looking thing right here. and Earth. Uh,
and it says it's it's uh used by the
sprites. So, this is a sprite. This is a
sprite. What is a sprite?
According to Miriam Webster's
dictionary, it says a sprite can be an
elf or a fairy or a disembodied spirit
or ghost or soul.
So,
that's part of the object of the game is
to collect these spirits.
And I'm not going to give it away. We're
going to continue walking through this
thing, but these spirits are good in the
game. They look so cute and cuddly. They
look like Kirby or something. And uh
they're just spirits of a certain
element, earth, wind, fire, or water,
which is all an occult practice. It's
elemental witchcraft. So, you see right
here, water sprites. Oh, water spirits.
Oh, it actually says spirits here. Air
sprites. Air spirit. Earth sprites.
Earth spirits. Now I want you to
remember what
on this right here where it says water
represents healing. Remember water
healing. Remember water healing because
this is this is real magic right here.
Elemental witchcraft. An elemental witch
is a partic a practitioner of witchcraft
who focuses their craft on the powers of
the natural elements earth, air, fire,
and water. Often working with one
specific element or all of them to
perform spells and rituals. Now, this is
me searching a cult. This is not based
on Fortnite. And right here, symbols of
elements, earth, air, fire, water. Look
what water represents. Connected to
emotions, intuition, the subconscious,
and healing. Wait a minute. Water
healing. Wait, back here, we just saw
water healing. Now, is this all just a
huge coincidence? Or are these people
literally involved in the cult? in the
occult. They're putting it in the game.
And this is literal witchcraft, digital
sorcery.
They're literally putting real
witchcraft in the game.
Now, I want you to notice what it says
right here at the bottom. Return
sprites. This is a a Facebook or this is
a YouTube video that somebody made who's
uh showing the game. And it says,
"Return sprites to a sprite shrine and
receive a boon." Now, these are some
weird words for people. Remember, this
is all kind of coded. These are words
that most of us don't know. Sprites,
sprite, shrine, receive a boon. Listen,
>> we can kind of, you know, Okay, let's
see. Let's see what happens. Let's see
what happens. Uh, return the sprite to
shrine.
Let's go. A little animation.
And we get what? Dude, that's like
Genshin Impact. That's so anime and
cool. I love Genshin. Uh, anyways,
that's a long animation.
Oh, he drops. Oo, he drops a boon and
some other stuff.
So, the object of the game is to find
these sprites, these spirits that
represent one of the elements. Find the
water sprite, take it to the sprite
shrine. It'll spin around and it'll give
you a boon. Do it with all the elements.
Earth, wind, fire, water. Look what this
boon looks like. A boon is this card
that's right there in front of him. You
notice this card? It's very much like a
tarot card and it says wind boon.
Now,
none of this stuff is just coincidental.
Check this out. What is a sprite shrine?
Bring a sprite to one of the forgotten
sprite shrines around the island.
Remember, the island is called the demon
island, the island of demons.
to this is so crazy. You're on demon
island. You're taking spirits to the
spirit shrine and and you're going to
gain a powerful boon. What do these
words mean?
A shrine.
By dictionary definition, a shrine is a
place regarded as holy because of its
association with a divinity or a sacred
person or relic. So the shrine is this
building constructed for a god. It's a
sacred holy place where you're taking
these spirits to
occult definition of boon. I was
actually skeptical. I was like boon?
That's not going to be anything. What is
boon? In an occult context, a boon is a
divine favor, blessing, or gift. That's
what we just saw, right? You got a gift
from the spirit. Typically granted by a
supernatural entity such as a god spirit
or powerful magical being. That's
literally what happens in the game. You
take the spirit, you take it to the
shrine, which is a building constructed
to a god or a deity, and it gives you a
boon, which is a gift given by a spirit
or a god.
And then it says right here that a boon
is not a simple favor. It comes from a
powerful nonhuman source. The gift is
tied to that entity's unique power. So
that's why when you get a, you know, an
air sprite, you take it to the shrine
and you get the wind boon or something
like that, right? Air wind. It's tied to
it. This is so mind-blowing. This is
literally verbatim witchcraft. This is
not just some fantasy game like, "Oh,
this is kind of cute. You take this
little cute guy and you take him to this
little platform and he gives you a
card." No, it's literally verbatim
witchcraft. Look what it says. High
stakes. The granting of a boon often
involves a significant event or bargain
with emotional or moral consequence.
So, in order to get that boon from a
spirit or god, there comes a consequence
with it. a moral consequence or
emotional. That sounds terrible.
It says, "A boon may be given as a gift,
but it can also be a part of a pact or
contract between the mortal and the
supernatural entity.
In this game, you're making a pact, a
contract with a spirit that you took to
a shrine.
This is insane."
and potential to become a curse. That
thing can become a curse. In the in the
game, there are spell books, a book of
spells where you can cast spells.
Crazy, man. There are characters you can
pick that are called the from their oak
oak witch academy. When you think of the
word uh oak tree that that ties into the
druids, they were all about the oak
trees. So you have these oak witches and
it says that these are some skins that
you can get. Some skins directly
reference figures like demons, witches,
and devils. Oh, fun for all ages for the
kids. Other cosmetics like pentagram
like symbols have drawn criticism and
accusations of including satanic
symbols. Now, I'm glad it brought that
up because I asked Google
if uh Fortnite is evil.
And it says whether Fortnite is
considered evil
depends whether Fortnite is considered
evil, quote unquote evil, depends on an
individual's values and beliefs. And it
says right here, it's like, oh, there's,
you know, there's some things in there
like selling your soul. No big deal.
Selling your soul. Wow. Really? To a
character, which could desensitize
younger players. All right. online
concerns raised by critics. There's
online predators in there. You got to be
careful because there's people that
might try to come to your house and uh
look, the predator is to groom your
children by building trust. I guess
that's that's a concern in any kind of
online platform, but definitely be aware
of that. Emotional impact.
Desensitization to dark themes. Wow,
that's really on there. A specific
update allows players to offer health to
a character in exchange for benefits, a
mechanic some see as a way to normalize
selling your soul to the devil.
Interesting. That's in Fortnite. Uh
kid-friendly content. Many argue that
Fortnite's cartoonish visuals,
lack of gore, and general light-hearted
nature make it suitable for younger
audiences, especially when compared to
more violent games. So this right here
is telling you this is targeted towards
your children. The game that where you
literally do virtual witchcraft in the
game. Remember games are teaching you
something. Simulators, how to drive, how
to fly, how to handle a hostage
situation, how to perform magic, how to
talk to how to make packs with spirits,
how to sell your soul to Satan.
Man, this is so crazy.
Misinterpretation. Some interpret some
interpretations of dark themes such as
hidden symbolisms and skins or the
selling your soul mechanic may be
exaggerated or misconstrued especially
by those with strong religious beliefs.
Dude, this is so
this is so bias and antichrist. It is
crazy.
So, here's some other things, some other
elements that you can get in the game.
Void element. Remember, oni mask again,
it says primarily used by demons and oni
masks. Uh, zero is another. It says
something right here about the the spire
cult. There's a cult
in the game that you can join. Oh,
interesting. I didn't even notice that.
How about this dark element?
Why is it all dark? Why is it Why is it
void zero dark chaos? Chaos magic.
That's Alistar Crowley stuff. The name
mag the named magic utilized by Diego.
Man, this is crazy. The magic the oni
masks
shadow. This guy's levitating in the
lotus position like new age meditation
called shadow. Again, dark elements.
Shadow and oh, right in your face.
Demonic. Demonic element. Oh, why don't
we get that one? A subcategory of dark
magic primarily used by Shogun X the
puppeteer. This magic has been used to
curse the night rose into servitude.
This is just crazy. This magic also
allows teleportation
and strengthens other magics.
So, it's obviously a good thing to get
because it comes with some very cool
powers.
Spire's flame says a subcategory of dark
magic. Oh, this is also primarily used
by the Spire cult. The cult. Join that.
and uh arcane magic that has a hexog
right here and a bunch of runes all over
it. It says a type of magic primarily
used by Dr. Doom and Pandora's box. Uh
arcane artifacts in a runic form. Again,
rune magic.
What in the world, man? This says Ko's
Ko Thorn's vampiric powers. a vampiric
power that allows the users
to siphon life force. So, you're sucking
life out of other people. And oh, it
doesn't show it. It doesn't show them
sucking blood. It's just, you know, the
life goes down. You're a vampire.
Fletcher Kane's aura. We got auras in
here now. It just keeps on going.
Give them give a red dark aura enhancing
the physical abilities of its user. All
these things are good. If you get these
things, they're good for you.
And Jade's power, a spiritual power.
Wait a minute. You know, anyone that
tries to mock and ridicule and say,
"Man, you're just making something out
of nothing. Why are there spiritual
elements in a game? I thought
spiritualism was for church. I thought
spiritualism was religion." And in the
same breath, these people that are
saying, "Oh man, you're just digging too
deep." And all that stuff will say,
"Stop shoving your religion down my
throat." What religion is being shoved
down everyone's throat through addictive
gaming where millions of people are
playing it? It looks like the occult. It
looks like spellbooks, witchcraft,
talking to making packs with spirits,
spiritual power exclusive to Jade,
connecting her directly to the island,
the demon island. Let me go back and
allowing her to feel the sprites or feel
the spirits as well as talk to them. So,
she has the power to talk to spirits and
feel them.
Here's a clip um where you can actually
sell your soul to the devil. Apparently,
in the new Fortnite update, you can sell
your soul to the devil.
And the first thing I just want to say
is this is a children's game. You know,
this is the lord of the underworld,
Satan, the evil one, the prince of the
power of the air, the ruler of this
world, and we make light of it.
Desensitize kids, making it seem like no
big deal. So, here they go. So, you
could offer your health to him,
basically selling your soul. You don't.
Anyway,
the dialogue kids game again, guys. Your
children play this. How lucky am I to
witness his eternal torment? He said,
"Wow."
We offer 99 health to raise up his dead
teammate.
So, you saw his health bar go down,
right? He had he had uh a full health
bar. Of course, now it's going to be
covered up, but he had a full health
bar. Made a deal with the devil. His
health bar went all the way down to the
lowest it can possibly be and still stay
alive. and he was able to resurrect one
of his teammates. Made a deal with the
devil.
Psalm 101:3
says, "I will set nothing wicked before
my eyes. I hate the work of those who
fall away. It shall not cling to me."
Any Christian, any bibleelving follower
of Christ cannot play this game
in good conscience.
I'm plug my laptop in real quick.
If we believe the Bible, the Bible says,
"I will set nothing wicked before my
eyes." What does that include? Video
games, movies, pornography,
nothing wicked before my eyes.
Romans 1:32. This is so convicting
because a lot of people say, "You know
what? It's just fantasy, man. I'm not
into witchcraft. I just like Harry
Potter. I just like the movie. It's
fantasy, dude. I know the difference in
fiction and reality. That's always the
go-to answer. I know the difference in
fiction and reality. Well, Romans 1:32
says, "Who knowing the judgment of God,
that they which commit such things are
worthy of death. Those who do the sinful
act are worthy of death." But it
continues, "Not only do the same, but
have pleasure in them that do them."
So you might say, "I would never do
witchcraft, but I love Harry Potter."
You might say, you know, I would never
be a homosexual, but I am an ally. I I'm
supportive of Pride Month, and I go to
the parades just to support, right? I
take pleasure in those that do the
sinful things that deserve death. I
would never kill anyone, but I love
playing a game for hours upon end where
I'm murdering non-stop. A murder
simulator. I would never do witchcraft,
but in the virtual world, I love using
my spell book. I love turning into a
ghost and flying around. I love grabbing
spirits and making a pact with them to
get that boon.
This is serious stuff.
Satan has desensitized us and he's
repackaged the occult in these colorful
movies and cartoons and video games and
purposely making them addictive to
enslave you to the occult
and you don't even care. The people
playing is like, I love it. It's fun.
There's nothing wrong with it. They've
been blinded by the god of this world.
The Bible says this.
Jesus taught that sin starts in the
mind, in the heart. Matthew 5:27 through
and 28 says, "You have heard that it was
said that though uh to those of old, you
shall not commit adultery. But I say,
Jesus says to you that whoever looks at
a woman to lust after her has already
committed adultery with her in his
heart."
So just to look with lust is the same as
doing it because it's all in the mind.
God cares about transforming us, making
us a new creature in Christ, renewing
our mind so that we're not even thinking
on the same things anymore. And yes,
we're fallen. We're fallen creatures.
I'm not going to say I'm perfect. We're
fallen creatures. But there's a saying
that says you can't stop a bird from
flying over your head, but you can stop
it from building a nest in your hair.
Just because some wicked thought comes
to your mind doesn't mean you have to
dwell on it and ponder it and say maybe
I should look at it on my phone,
just because that thought comes in your
mind. You right then you say, "God, give
me the strength not not to fall into
this trap. I'm being tempted right now.
It's not a sin to be tempted." Jesus was
tempted in the wilderness in ways that
we could never imagine. He's starving.
Turn this bread into turn this stone
into bread. Bow to me and I'll give you
all the kingdoms of the world. You don't
have to be a a homeless person with no
place to lay your head. I'll give you
everything. Bow to me. Jesus was
tempted. It was not a sin to be tempted.
We're going to be faced with temptation.
We're in a fallen world. Satan is the
tempter. He's trying to get us left and
right. And his full attack is on the
Christians. He doesn't have to go after
the the lost world. They're already
enslaved to alcohol and marijuana and
video games and going to the club and
all that stuff. He doesn't even have to
focus on them. They're already locked
in.
His primary attack is on believers, on
Christians. It's time for the church to
wake up. Stop playing around. Stop being
one foot in the church, one foot in the
world. Jesus is coming soon. Are you
ready?
I think so many of us aren't. And I pray
earnestly for myself. God, make me
ready. Ephesians 6:12 says, "For we do
not wrestle against flesh and blood, but
against principalities, against the
powers, against the rulers of the
darkness of this age, against spiritual
hosts of wickedness in heavenly places."
We're dealing with something that is far
beyond what we could ever imagine.
Spiritual foes, interdimensional
deceivers that are so intelligent
they can deceive a perfect Eve in a
perfect garden.
How much more of a of of prey are we?
We are fallen beings who have been
groomed generation by generation o
through culture and oh it's pop culture
oh it's acceptable now and you know you
know it's okay to drink and it's okay to
fornicate and you know
even the Christian church is doing these
things
fornicating smoking marijuana drinking
alcohol watching rated R movies maybe
even watching porn playing video games
that are addictive, that are filled with
occult themes and murder.
We're dealing with a supernatural foe.
We stand no chance if we are not in
God's word and on our knees in prayer
every day, begging God, "Give me eyes to
see. Open my eyes, Lord. I've been
deceived. I'm sick of I'm sick of the
deception. I'm sick of the lies. I want
the truth. Open my eyes, God. Give me
spiritual eyes because spiritual things
are spiritually discerned. It's not just
a video game. It's not Frogger. It's not
crossing the street anymore. It's
literally like we're doing witchcraft in
a virtual world. It's a simulation.
2 Corinthians 10:4-5 says, "For the
weapons of our warfare are not carnal,
but mighty through God to the pulling
down of strongholds." These are
strongholds in our life, but our weapons
are not carnal. We're not going to do
this in our own strength. We're going to
do it on our knees. We're coming to God
in prayer and saying, "God, I am weak,
but you are strong. You give me the
strength. Take this out of my life. I'm
sick of being a slave to it." Casting
down imaginations.
Why would it even say anything about
your imagination if it didn't matter? If
it only mattered what you did with your
hands or what you did physically.
casting down imaginations and every high
thing that exaltth itself against the
knowledge of God and bring into
captivity every thought to the obedience
of Christ. We have to surrender our even
our very thoughts to Christ. Let alone
you're playing a video game and being
entertained by witchcraft and perversion
and sorcery and all these things. Murder
being entertain I mean just just think
realistically.
Does it sound normal to be entertained,
take pleasure and joy in in murdering
people left and right? That's crazy. I
mean, that's literally insane to think.
I mean, if you if you grew up with
somebody and he was like, "You know
what? I think it would just be fun to
just kill an animal." You would be
terrified of that person. You would tell
an adult. They would give them
psychotherapy.
But you know what to just, you know, in
in like Grand Theft Auto, it's like kill
everything, pedestrians, cops, whatever.
And it's fun, right? Oh, we have a blast
playing those games.
Revelation 12:9 says, "And the dragon
was cast out, the old serpent called the
devil and Satan, which deceiveth the
whole world." Not just a small portion,
not just the lost people. He deceives
the whole world. He was cast out into
the earth and his angels were cast out
with him. There are wicked angels,
fallen angels all around this world.
Interdimensional beings trying to
deceive you any way possible. Trying to
get you involved in the occult, trying
to get you involved in new age, trying
to get you to go to the wrong church
that's teaching false doctrine.
But God says, "Come out of her, my
people." He's pleading with his people,
"Come out of her. I'm begging you.
2 Corinthians 2:11, "Lest Satan should
get an advantage of us, for we are not
ignorant of his devices."
It's it's just mind-blowing that how in
your face we call these things our
devices, right? Vices. They're vices.
De vices in our life. games, movies,
phones, social media, whatever it is,
these are vices in our life.
And the Bible is giving us the answers.
We need to expose these things. Expose
the darkness so that we will not fall
for his tricks so that we are not
ignorant. Burying our head in the sand.
No, we don't want to talk about that.
We're not going to bury our head in the
sand. We're not going to be ignorant of
his devices. We're going to expose them.
put him on blast. Throw it out to the
internet to see. Share this with your
family and friends because they need to
know.
So, what things can we partake in? I'm
going to put this full screen
as believers. We get this question all
the time like what can we watch? What
can this is like a a first world problem
like what can we watch? You know, what
are we supposed to do? What did people
watch 300 years ago? And all the way
before that, people weren't going out of
their mind because they couldn't stare
at a a screen, a glowing rectangle for
hours. Philippians 4:8 says, "Whatsoever
things are true, whatsoever things are
honest, whatsoever things are just,
whatsoever things are pure, whatsoever
things are lovely, whatsoever things are
of good report, if there be any virtue,
and if there be any praise, think on
these things."
God's telling us, look,
think on things that are pure and lovely
and true.
Now, that word true doesn't mean like it
can't be fiction, but the the moral has
to be true. It can't you can't be
entertaining yourself with something
that's saying God is a villain or that
we need to have sympathy for the devil.
That's not true. That's not pure. It's
not lovely and there's no virtue or
praise in it.
We need to be unique. We need to stand
out. We need to be a leader. We need to
be We need to set the trends and not
just follow the crowd.
You know, I think that's what so many of
us do. We're just like, "Well, everyone
else is doing it. I don't want to be a
weirdo. You know, I feel I don't feel
awkward if I don't go to that movie with
all my friends that are going." Look,
dude, it's so much cooler to be
different and not be a clone of everyone
else.
Will you cho choose to enter the narrow
door? Jesus said, "There's a broad way
to death and destruction, but there's a
narrow way,
the way to life, and only few will there
be that find it." Will you choose that
today? I hope this was eye opening. I
hope this was something that if you
never heard this before, you can share
this with your family and friends. If
you have a child that's addicted to this
game, they need to know the truth about
this. If you're a parent that has
allowed your kid to play this game
because you didn't know, now you know.
Now the ball is in your court. Are we
going to keep indulging in virtual
simulators about murder,
perversion, the occult,
literally doing what we're taking
pleasure in the things that God said
are debaucherous,
are an abomination in his sight, things
that were worthy of death. If you're
blessed by this video, please give a
thumbs up. It really helps this video
get into the al out into the algorithm
so that other people can see this truth
that needs to be heard.
If you want to support this ministry,
you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org.
We have a lot of different digital ways
to give. Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal.
We even have Patreon. If you like
t-shirts, you can go to our site. We
have a a merch section. We got a lot of
cool t-shirts with Bible verses and
things like it's cool to use your brain
because so many people are not doing
that these days. And we love you guys.
We we thank you because without your
support, we can't do this. We stepped
out in faith just over a year ago. God
has been providing through faithful
donors like you. Thank you to all our
Patreon supporters. Thank you to those
who are sending checks in the mail and
cash in the mail or um just any gift
that you're giving. We thank you. We
love you. We cannot do this without you.
We will see you next time on Can of
Truth.